and I just like wanted one and I finally
got that brother and I was like oh I he
can't do anything like he's useless
until like yeah for a long time and then
by the time I like I went to college
when I was 18 you know he was 11 so like
now we were very very close but I think
it's just having being closer in age I
think if he was like two years younger
than me we'd be much much closer is he a
Steelers fan yes wow you Pittsburgh you
have to be yeah yeah it's tough this
year but uh it's been Rocky man I wanted
to buy in uh pick it right and I say you
know y all I think part ofy always
cheers for the Steelers I mean cuz I'm a
Saints fan and they're black and gold
Steelers are black and gold and I love
Steelers you know I you know I'd always
go up there you hear all these crazy
rumors about Cordell steart and Shenley
Park you'd hear all of this you know you
people's just saying than tank you know
you'd hear all of it you know
um and so yeah I always want them to do
well but and then I saw him with that
mustache and I'm like this means he's
going to do well cuz you don't grow a
mustache I think unless you're planning
on doing some where I'm from yeah and uh
and then he just hasn't been able to
really put it together yet I think he
hasn't been that bad I think it's like I
think it's everybody I don't think like
everyone's like it's the coaching I'm
like no it's it's not just the players
it's everyone just kind of just being a
little bit off I think we'll pull it
together I think we'll will'll be you
know a game over 500 maybe game under
maybe break Tomlin streak but I'm the
kind of fan who I just want to support
I'm I like the coaches I like the
players like if they get traded like I
still like them I'm just I just happy
that the team is there I don't get mad
yeah you know I don't get mad about the
Steelers anymore I used to and then I
kind of just realized like this is
stupid why am I ruining like
relationships with people like there was
a game once I think I just moved to LA
and the Steelers played the Patriots it
was the year that Brady won his first
Super Bowl when they had like beaten the
Raiders was a miracle and the Steelers
were really heavily favored and then we
just got crushed and all my friends were
at my place and they were all Patriots
fans except for me oh and I got hammered
and like yelled at everybody like it was
such an embarrassing game and I snapped
that I was so embarrassed that I
couldn't talk to my friends for like a
week and then I was like I'm never doing
this again I'm going to be on emotional
lock down for sporting events from now
on it's just it's stupid stupid you put
a lot into it yeah and you see people
put their whole lives into it and they
cart their wife out there and they'll
paint their wife the colors of the team
and they'll do all of that you know what
got me uh remember when the Red Sox won
the first World Series and forever you
know it was like early mid 2000s or
something and I remember being pumped
for them I had a bunch of friends who
were Red Sox fans and I was rooting for
them to win that year and then after
they won I was happy and then the next
season the fans were like the same
it was like they the guy from
momento who doesn't know he killed the
dude and he's just like I got to kill
this guy it's like you killed him you
already won and they didn't didn't bring
them that much joy that I don't want to
be that kind of fan yeah I want to just
always be happy for my team yeah I think
that's what I'm I I I I've struggled to
have that I realize it's like am I a
fair weather fan I was a Die Hard Saints
fan growing up die hard I remember when
I have any money I made like Saints
merchandise and I go out there and sell
bootleg merchandise you know and I loved
them you know yeah I love the Saints and
it just uh but at a certain point it
just I don't know also got a little bit
older I think you start to realize like
I'm bus I maybe my life I got busier too
I didn't have as much time to do fantasy
I don't know I never I never done
fantasy I've never wanted to really I
never want to root for anyone who's not
a stealer I never want to be like oh you
know Calvin Ridley just you know ran all
over us but he's on my he's on my
fantasy team so I'm happy about that
like I never wanted to do that wow
you're really pure then you're kind of a
purest and I also just don't want to
like type in all that I don't want
to sit there for the draft you know like
one of my best friends is like one of
the uh like a big fantasy football guy
like knows everything would if he ran
your team you would win and I just I
would never give a not my thing I
don't gamble do you gamble do you put
money on Sports I do gamble sometimes I
realized recently that I need to kind of
chill out you know not a lot I'll bet
like a couple hundred dollar here and
there on something I've never bet $1,000
on something but um I do realize it's
like I'm getting a little like when I
get like testy or bored I want to do
something you know you need to misbehave
I'm like that where I'm like yes like
I'm like I don't I haven't had to drink
in like a year and a half I almost
consider myself
I don't consider myself sober but I
haven't been drinking but I need
something I need like a nicotine pouch
or like some sort of like thing that's
like this is my
misbehaving